we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
very interesting voicemail about a
caller who's reconsidering what he
believes might be may or might be might
be is a combination of those two which
i've just created acceptable tactics in
politics and activism take a listen and
let's discuss hi david i'll get right
into it i have always been very firmly
in the violence is not the answer camp
yes and while i still find myself very
dedicated to preventing violence against
people I've been re-evaluating and
having to go back to my opinions on that
regarding things like machinery and I'm
unsure as to where I stand morally on
this for example of what I'm thinking
about is things like feeling the seats
from bulldozers or removing a key piece
of equipment that allows fracking
fracking rigs to keep operating and I
was curious as to what your thoughts are
on this because I'm in a state of moral
ambiguity regarding it anyway um thank
you and I'll be watching your show hope
to hear your response a very good
evening good night I want to address
this so I have always indicated that I
am against violence and criminality and
political activism but that at a certain
point we do need to seriously consider
different types of civil disobedience we
need to consider general strikes we need
to consider really the protests that are
going to achieve change are going to
have to be outside of the bounds of what
the status quo tells us protests should
be right the status quo is never going
to put their blessing on tactics that
might actually have a change of change
have a chance at changing the status quo
because they don't want the status quo
to be changed so I'm against violence
I'm against physical violence I've said
I'm against criminality and destruction
of property
the caller is starting to bring up
things that are sort of in between so
like if there are going to be bulldozers
used to do something that's terrible for
the climate you could go in and steal
the seat from the bulldozer so that the
bulldozer opera
Raider is not going to be able to
operate it because there's no seat
there'll just be a pole which would go
somewhere uncomfortable if they were to
sit down on it that is a crime okay so
if your position is you should not use
criminality to do political activism
then you would say that that's over the
line now is it violence I don't think as
long as you're not grabbing the operator
of the piece of equipment throwing them
out and stealing the seat it is not
physical violence but it is still a
crime so in those cases I would say I'm
not ideologically opposed to it on the
basis of it being violent but if you're
going to commit crimes you need to
understand that there will be
consequences to those crimes and
well-meant many of the things that fall
under the umbrella of civil disobedience
there are also crimes - they are
criminal trespassing right yes and this
I think we could identify as sabotage
you know kind of the middle ground
between just speaking out is speaking
your mind basic protesting and violence
I think this is the middle ground here
what was the other example that that he
gave in addition to taking the seat off
of the bulldozer there was one other one
about fracking right oh yeah and right
so what if you do something to disable
vehicles or equipment that would be used
for fracking that is a it's a it's a
morally gray area it is legally not a
gray area but you could also make the
argument that these things have been
criminalized specifically by those who
are in power to prevent people from
doing them I think in any case stealing
pieces of equipment that you don't own
or parts of pieces of equipment that you
don't own is by any reasonable standard
going to be criminal but I do think that
morally there there are there is a gray
area there but to be clear I'm not
advocating that people do any of this
stuff I'm merely saying you are right
that this is not beating people up this
is not physical violence in the sense
that almost everyone would be opposed to
great bonus show today I'm out of time
to tell you what's on it but I will
speak to you then